is back um so yeah so we're going to
have uh a three-part tutorial on lecture
on probabilistic and combinatorial
methods in coding Theory by uh Jonathan
MF and this is part one and parts two
and three will be tomorrow thank
you okay hi everyone uh yeah so methods
um so what are we going to talk
about um there's lots of things I want
to tell you um and
if we have time we'll get to more than
just whatl here but at least we're going
to
do uh here uh so the questions we're
going to be talking about are going to
beori uh which means that they're not
algorithmic uh we're not going to like
we're we're not going to prove anything
about uh complexity of decoding or
questions like that like that the sort
of questions that we will be uh trying
to answer is whether certain codes are
uh list decodable or List recoverable uh
um up to some parameters in the
combinatorial
sense um so an example motivation um is
the question of how list decodable and
how list recoverable are read Solon
codes okay up to what uh uh radius can
we uh uh for example list the code uh
Sol in code again not algorithmically at
just um just uh in the combinatorial
sense information sense uh I put this
icon here because um this involves
certain uh open um certain open problems
like some of this has been recently
solved but a lot of this Still Remains
open uh so uh we'll see what it was
um and the star player in these talks is
actually going to be the humble random
linear
code So Random linear code is a very
very basic construct we're trying to
Define exactly what we mean by random
linear code soon um and maybe in a sense
the the the technique uh that a lot of
what we're going to do uh
involves is first getting some
understanding about what I random linear
code does how a random linear code
behaves and then reducing for random
linear code to more structured code so
we'll see uh for example how uh we can
infer something about the behavior of
readed Solon codes which are very
interesting to us because they are
structured and have some nice algorithms
uh and very important how we can use uh
um things we know about a random linear
code and infer from them about these
more structured and sophisticated codes
okay so this is going to be uh the main
technique uh that we'll be exploring and
really uh in this first talk I think
most of what we'll have time to do is to
concentrate solely on random linear
codes
themselves um and as we progress we'll
be able to see how our knowledge of
random linear codes uh can be used for
um can be used towards other
more complicated
Cod okay so let's define the basic
amatorial Notions that we care about so
we know what's list decoding I'll just
say it quickly right so so unique
decoding we say that the code is RO
unique decodable uh if given uh row and
arrows the uh receiver can can always uh
uniquely recover code word so in other
words uh we need for not to be if our
code's in fq to the end we need to avoid
having a ball in fq to the end that
contains two or more code words okay B
radius row uh in this decoding uh we
relax this uh the unique decoding uh uh
requirement and we only want the uh
receiver to be able to recover some list
uh of possible uh uh um of possible code
words of size at most l so we allow say
uh uh two code words in a ball but we
don't want there to be more than L Okay
so if no ball contains more of an L code
words uh we say that the code is list
codable with parameters row and L and
again we don't care about right now
about how uh the receiver is going to
algorithmically find these code words we
just care that this the list itself is
small uh then we also have list recovery
um so in list decoding we care about
Hamming balls we want Hamming balls not
to have too many code words in this
recovery We Care instead about
combinatorial rectangles so we want
every combinatorial re rectangle in fq
to the N not to contain too many code
words and for we say that the code in fq
to the N is list recoverable with input
list size little L and output list Size
Big L if the following holds uh for
every we take for every set of letters
for each coordinate okay so we encod we
call them S1 to SN and these are going
to be uh uh little L letters for each
coordinate
um the product of these uh uh of these
sets S1 tosm that's called that's called
the combinatorial rectangle okay so that
would be all the code all the words that
fall uh uh within the given input list
in each coordinate and we want the
intersection of the code with such a
Comal rectangle not to be too large we
want it to contain it most again Big L
code words and if this holds for every
commun re angle we say that the code is
little L Big L is recoverable
okay okay now to our star player the
random linear code which is most of what
we'll be talking about uh this
hour
um okay so Random linear code is just uh
a uniformly sampled linear Subspace of
Dimension RN in
fq and the reason one of the reasons we
like random linear codes is that this is
the go to code for existing proofs
usually if we want to know whether there
exist a Cod exists a code with a certain
combinatorial property um it's usually
it usually makes sense to first ask is
it true that a random linear code has
this property uh and sometimes even this
leads to uh very complicated questions
uh so fully understanding or almost
fully understanding uh listability of
random linear
codes I think we can say that right now
we really answered almost every question
about ltic codability ofar codes but
this is like rather ver like very very
new stuff and it's been uh there's many
papers about this and we still don't
fully understand list recoverability of
even of random linear code so even these
are tough questions uh but still
sometimes they're easier to answer for
random linear code than for certain you
know more
structured okay um yeah so things that
we do know about random linear codes is
that they achieve the gilboard vov bound
and we also achieve uh what I call this
is not a standard uh this is not a
standard notion but what I call the list
decoding GV Bound in a sense they are as
list decodable as uh plain random code
uh so uh what does that mean it means
that
uh um if I want to list the code um
sorry this should be this probably be a
if I want to let's decode uh up to some
radius Delta with list size L uh then 1
minus HQ Delta is the gap to is is the
capacity uh and I can take uh if I go
within a factor of one over L from The
Gap to capacity I should be able to do
that with randomly code okay so any code
satisfying this you don't really like if
you if these parameters don't sit well
with you right now you can forget about
them it's not like this this specific
trade-off is not very important but
there is this trade-off called the list
coding GV bound and if a code achieves
that we it's in a sense we it's achieves
what we believe to be optimally optimal
ltic codability yes it's an existence
there exists a code that has that yeah
yeah yeah and then these are in a sense
the best that we know to exist so so
yeah so so I mean so that would be like
the analog of achieving that's why I
call the list decoding GV bound because
that's the analog of achieving uh for
actually um Henry raised a very
important point please ask questions
uh okay uh would be really helpful and
there also many list recovery results
about trom codes again we don't fully
understand but we do know that they are
rather they do rather well with regard
toil okay so these codes are great
what's bad with them uh what's bad with
them is that they're not structured and
so algorithmically we can't do anything
okay so decoding them is almost
certainly hard problem uh
certifying the properties on the left is
almost certainly a hard problem okay so
given a random linear code I want to
prove that it's you I want to check
whether it actually achieved the
gilboard for sham down I don't know how
to do that and constructing them is is
you know it's a random process it takes
uh around uh N squared random bits if I
want to construct a random linear code
in F2 why because I need to generate
either um a random generating Matrix or
a random par check Matrix in each of
these would have AIO of n squ Bits okay
so this is the good and the bad but
yes this is for random orom what
sorry so randomly your codes achieve
this with the one L dependence no yeah
sorry with the one
L um didn't you show that like for large
C no for small for small q this was
already
known oh I guess there's an intermediate
Gap um for like for yeah that's why I
said okay yeah so this is like all yeah
when I said that we know almost
everything we you know yeah there is
some Gap left there we can I mean I'd
love to discuss it with you later I
think we're like like for a few people
in this room who are interested in this
uh like in this resolution of this
discussion and we're two of them so yeah
let's talk about this later but it
almost in yeah uh but in a large sense
yes for most SP regimes random codes do
this
okay to work with random linear
codes there's one thing you need to know
so this is going to be the only thing
you need to know about the about random
linear
codes and this is what's the probability
that random linear code contains a set
of vectors I have a set of
vectors what's the probability that a
random linear code is going to contain
it so maybe I should first ask I didn't
write this here but what's the
probability that a plain random code
plain random code is just like when you
you know just a random subset so what's
the probability that a plain random code
contains the set of vectors V1 to VK
assume that K is some constant okay like
think of K as being 100 not uh I don't
know n okay so take some small number of
vectors the plain random code contains a
given Vector with probability 2us one- R
* n okay this is just the probability
that a given Vector is contained a set
and in a plain random code if you want
to contain you know all of the set you
just multiply the exponent by the size
of the set so you put K here for random
linear code because of the
linearity
containing uh a bunch of vectors
actually means containing the Subspace
stand by them right it's the same thing
and the thing we care about is the
dimension of the of the of the Subspace
that they span so if these vectors are
highly linearly dependent when the
probability of containing them is much
larger because there's less because we
only care about the Dem okay so so so
this probability the probability of
containing a set is going to be again
2us oneus RN which is just like this
this on the rate of the code times the
dimension of the set span by V1 to VK
and this is really the only thing you
need like all the properties of random
linear codes uh that we're going to talk
about come from this
observation so let's talk about list the
codability of random code again maybe
I'll say again right now we're talking
about random linear codes and our
motivation eventually is going to is to
be able to talk about other codes such
as read Solon codes using what we're
doing right now but right now in this
specific part let's assume that we don't
have all the really nice results about
listed codability of random linear codes
that have been achieved throughout the
last 20 or so years uh we're just
getting to this problem for the first
time and we want to show that a Rand
that a binary random linear code
achieves the list decoding GV okay we
want and again we don't need to know
what's the list decoding GV you just
want to know that you want to show that
it's list decodable of some good
parameters so yeah more precisely again
this is what the list coding GB says but
again we want to show that it's list
codable of
some so how do you go about doing that
here's one way to do it here's one
notion that we need this is the notion
of witnesses okay um if a code is not
list
decodable then there has to be some
witness to this fact how do I convince
you that a code is not less decodable I
just need to show you the vectors that
make it nless decodable right if I want
if I want to show you that a vector is
not that a code is like doesn't have
good distance I just need to show you
two code Words which are close to each
other if I want to convince you that
it's not row L is decodable I need to
show you L Plus vectors that all lie in
the same ball okay so if there are l+1
vectors that lie within some radius row
ball we say that they are clustered or
row clustered okay uh and this ttle X1
to XL plus1 we consider it a witness to
the non- this decodability
uh uh of a of a code C so if I want to
show that a random linear code is
probably this decodable I need to I need
there to be no
Witnesses um like okay
um okay so how do I
show um how can I try to show that
random linear code is this decodable or
that there are no
Witnesses um so a witness is a tle of
code words I just told you what's the
probability that a random linear code
contains a given tle of code words so
what I can try to do
is uh compute the expectation of the
number of witnesses okay the number of
cluster tles in a random linear code and
show that it goes to zero that it's
little o of one so it goes to zero if I
can show that then I'm done I showed
that the random linear code is list is
with high probability list codable just
because of the mark of bom right like
the probability that for exit witness is
at least the expected number of
witnesses if the expected number goes to
zero then the probability of not being
list decodable also goes to zero and
we're
good but now the question is is this
method type TI okay what do I mean by is
this method tight so this is actually
something okay so this is actually
something that came up research uh I was
working with vut and Nick on this
specific question in some guys and we
were trying to compute these
expectations and I asked myself
uh is it possible that we're going to
miss something okay like is it possible
that what we're doing for is it possible
that random linear codes are less
decodable with the pro with the
parameters that we want but Computing
the but by Computing expectations we can
show that okay that maybe just this
expectation method is too weak because I
don't know maybe the expect the expected
number of witnesses is large but for
some reason the probability of her being
a witness is still small right this can
happen random variables where the
expectation is large but the probability
of them being non zero is is actually
very very small so what could this be
the
case and yeah and and and it turned out
that okay I I'll spoil it for you yes
this is the case the expectation method
as I described it just counting the
expected number of witnesses is not
tight in general or in some generality
um so the first intuition was yeah maybe
it's not tight why could it maybe be not
tight because of an analogy from the
world of random graphs which I'm going
to show you
now okay
um so here is a completely different
question so for those of you who don't
know a
G&P random graph is a graph with n
vertices where okay so n choose two
possible edges and each each uh uh
possible Edge will occur with
probability
p and p and and the edges are uh are
independent from each other okay so
that's a model it's called the Earth
training model for uh random graphs um
and people have been studying these for
much longer than they've been studying
random linear
codes yeah not much longer a bit longer
uh there's been more study of these uh
definitely and um one of the basic
questions is okay let's choose some some
small graph
H um what's the probability that a G&P
graph contains an H or
more specifically how do I know given H
and given this P whether uh the
probability that g& P will contain a
copy of H inside it is goes to zero or
goes to
one so what you can try to do is compute
the expected number of
hes inside G so how many ways are like
how many ways are to for H Ur G so the
number of ways to you know um uh to put
these five vertices inside the vertices
of G is roughly n the five uh and for
each top each five vertices in G that
were chosen there are seven edges one
two three four five six seven that need
to occur so the probability given such
an embedding a possible embedding of H
into G that this embedding will actually
give you a copy of H is p to the seven
okay so this gives you the expected
number of hes in
G however the
thickens because you can all agree with
me that in
order for the graph G to contain an H it
must in particular contain this click
which I call
S I mean containing s is a is AE is a
necessary condition for containing H and
number of s's in G the expect number of
H it's one vertx less and one Edge less
so it's n 4 P to 6
and the thing is for some range of P
okay when p is n to the alpha and Alpha
is within this range then the expected
it's not now you can easy say this for
yourself the expected number of H's is
going to go to Infinity but the expected
number of s's is going to go to
zero so we know that with high
probability G does not contain an S
therefore with high probability does not
contain an H
um however the number of H the expected
number of hes in G does go to Infinity
so this is exactly an example of a
random variable whose expectation goes
to infinity even though its probability
of being positive is very very small
okay um so this is what happens so so
the so the thing is that the expectation
method the analog of what we're trying
to do for codes turns out not to be
tight for random graphs fortunately we
do know what is tight for random graphs
yeah so this is just what I said right
almost surely there's not a single H can
be found in G even though in expectation
many such subgraphs appear oh maybe I'll
say one more thing just nice intuition
so how why why is it that there are many
hes an
expectation uh even though probably not
even single water appears because the
probability of having an s in the graph
is an unlikely event but if this
unlikely event happens then this copy of
s is going to have many you know leaves
coming out of it and each one of these
gives you a copy of H okay so in the
unlikely event of containing an S it's
going to have you're going to have many
hes not just one okay and this is this
is how we got to this strange uh
phenomenon okay so thank thankfully
there's a classic theorum about random
graphs that tells us what is the case
Okay so right so what we saw is that
okay it's not enough to consider the
expected number of H's we also need to
consider the expected number of s's and
of course of any subgraph of
H and babash in 1981 told us that this
is enough okay so if I want to know
whether I whether an H is going to be in
my graph I need to look at the expected
number of hes and also the expected
number of
any uh subgraph of H and if one of these
expectations go to zero then I'm not
going to have hes obviously but if all
of these and and what B show is that if
all of these expectations go to Infinity
they always go to either zero or
Infinity okay it's just like a very very
small point where they go to neither so
imagine it's always either zero or
Infinity okay so if all these
expectations go to
Infinity then what the spum says is that
with high probability we will have an H
okay and if you're interested to know
how
uh how this is proven it's a pretty
straightforward proof uh I think the
hard part here is uh like understanding
what should be the right statement of
the theorem but once you have that it
really just comes from a second moment
uh arguments nothing very
spectacular so that means that okay
specifically for this graph H uh the
bottleneck comes from really from this s
okay so for every graph H where is a
subgraph which is like the the one that
needs P the large to be the largest in
order for the expectation to be when you
raise p uh at some point each subgraph
is going to go to infinity and when the
last one does that's the bottleneck then
you're start going to start having hes
okay so if you consider the
probability of GN P to contain an H then
really as you increase P then you get
this threshold here like up to some
point the probability is zero and then
once you reach a point where the prob
where the expected number of s's goes
from zero to Infinity then the
probability becomes almost one okay
that's enough about random graphs let's
get back to
codes okay so now we're going
to uh try and do the analog of this uh
for random linear codes so in order to
do that I need one more notation that's
going to help me um okay so suppose I
have a r set or actually any set of
vectors okay um it's going to be very
convenient to write sets of vectors as
matrices okay so if I have l+ one
vectors which would be a WID like if
they are in the code then they are bad
witness I'm going to write them as
Columns of this Matrix okay so this is a
very tall and thin Matrix because n goes
to infinity and this L plus one you can
think of it as some constant it has L
plus one
columns um and these are just like X1
would be this X2 would be this x
this
and I need the following observation
okay so I
have uh the family of all the bad
matrices okay bad matrices are matrices
that if they are in my code when the
code is not list decodable I want to
show that these are probably not in my
code so I just want to note that this
family is Clos is closed to row
permutations what does it
mean uh if I
switch um few coordinates here I switch
rows then obviously I'm not doing
anything to the
geometry of this set right the distances
are still the same I can it's just like
it's it's it's a it's equivalent to uh
row to permuting the coordinates of the
code which obviously does nothing to the
geometry so if some Matrix is a witness
then permuting its rows is also going to
give
me but what what does that mean suppose
I give you a matrix and I ask you to
tell me whether this Matrix is a witness
okay whether
The Columns of this Matrix together form
a set that's contained in a
ball and I just told
you that you don't need to know to know
the exact rows you only need to know how
many of each row this Matrix
has uh because that's what being closed
to rations means it means that if you
want to know whether the Matrix belongs
to the set you only need to know the uh
number of rows of each uh the number
occurrences of each s throw and then uh
uh any way you arrange them the rows in
order you're going to get uh witness is
that F2 to the l+ one or n oh sorry yeah
that should be F2 to the L plus one this
is a typo and tly very important Tyle
thank you
okay um and the thing is
that once instead of thinking okay so so
we can take
this uh set of witness
matrices and instead of thinking about
them as matrices we're just going to
think about their distributions okay how
many times does each row appear in such
a
matrix and the thing is that
this uh uh sort of projection this
projects the set of matrices into a much
much smaller space when I forget what's
the Matrix and I only remember its row
distribution so why is that because a
row distribution is like how many rows
how many possible rows are there here so
if this is a binary
Matrix um then there it has L plus one
columns so the number of each row can
take one of two to the L plus one
possible values because it's just a
vector of length l+ one so if I want to
know if I want to
remember um a
distribution right how many number
between zero and N how many of each type
of Matrix of each type of row I have
then obviously an upper Bound for how
many such distributions exist right each
distribution is like is a tople of uh
two to the L plus one numbers between
zero and N okay there should be an N
plus one here but uh uh that's the basic
uh okay that that that's the sort of um
that's the sort of uh uh um order of
magnitude that we're talking about and
this number is very small okay n to the
two to the L
uh L is
constant so n the 2 to the l+ one is a
polinomial in n and in everything we're
going to do here polinomial factors are
completely negligible because uh you
know when we talking about uh the number
say the probability of containing a set
for example in our code uh we've seen
that it's uh right it's a it's
exponential in N everything else is
exponential in N so promals are
completely negligible okay so that means
that when I think about the set of
witnesses for nonl decodability right I
have a set of bad Witnesses it's a
family of matrices I can
divide this family I can partition it
according to distribution now there's
not that many
distributions and I just need for like
in order to show in general that there
are no Witnesses in the code I just need
to show that for each of these bad
distributions there's no matrices of
that specific distribution in the code
and this is all what I'm doing here is
just trying to convince you that I can
reduce everything to this problem the
problem is now going to be set some
distribution okay so maybe I'll go back
anyway so choose some distribution some
row
distribution a specific row distribution
but that belongs to this set of bad
distributions and all I care about is to
show that for a given distribution
uh um there are probably no matrices
with that specific distribution in the
random linear code and then I can do
that separately by a union bound
separately for each of the bad
distributions okay so we we basically
reduce the problem to thinking about a
specific roow
distribution so now um the question is
uh the witnesses have b a bunch of bad
distribu B A bunch of witness
distributions and the question is uh uh
for a given one of of these
distributions can we show that a random
linear code with high probability does
not contain any Matrix with that
specific with that specific row
distribution where again containing a
matrix is containing it
cols
okay this is all I remind you that we're
talking about the expectation method so
we're still
hoping to compute the expected number of
matrices in the random linear code with
distribution this distribution to uh
where to is some bad
distribution um and we hope to show that
this number is small in this way uh show
that the code probably does not contain
any
Matrix so I just want to show you that
this is actually like for a given
distribution to this is actually a very
simple computation right um right so so
let to be some uh distribution over F2
to D l+1 and you want to know what's the
expected number of to distributed
matrices okay in in the code so to
distributed matrices are matrices where
the row distribute the rows are
distributed according to the specific to
that we've
set um and we want know what's the
probability but how many matrices with
this distribution we expect uh the code
to contain their
columns okay so what's this number it's
the number of to distributed matrices
okay the number of of matrices that have
to Z distribution times the probability
for such a given Matrix that its columns
are contained in the code now okay this
is some number that we know how to
compute given to it's basically if you
think about it it's just going to be 2
to the N times the entropy of this
distribution t uh if you don't see that
then that's fine if you do want I mean
you don't really need the this is just
like an you you don't need to understand
how where this came from but I'll tell
you anyway uh that uh right if you know
the distribution of a matrix then what
you really need to do now to create a
matrix with this
distribution um is you have n values
distributed according to to and you need
to somehow order
them um and this right this is a
multinomial variable which is exactly um
approximated by this and on the other
hand we also know what's the
probability uh this Matrix belong to the
that the given Matrix with this like
after we did the ordering what's the
probability that the given Matrix the
and one are at Dimension we know that
and the dimension know that it only
depends on to itself because if I know
what's the row distribution in
particular I know what rows are here
then I also I can also determine the
rank okay so the point is that this
gives me something that's really well
defined because it depends on the to
okay so I get this sort of expression
here 2 to the N times you know this
entropy of to minus one minus r the
dimension of something that's a we don't
really need to delve into
this but what you do need to know is
that as you increase
R up to some point this exponent here
this part of the exponent is going to be
negative so this expectation is going to
be very close to zero right because it's
going to be 2 to the N times this
negative number and then once you cross
the threshold where this part of the
exponent becomes positive then uh the
expectation slowly it is going to climb
to Infinity this is in some weird
scale okay like this is very this is
very close to infinity and this is very
close to
zero
um
okay
so okay so what does this computation
give us for a given
to so we know that as long as the rate
is in this range where the expectation
is close to zero
then C almost surely does not contain to
when I say contain to I mean almost
surely does not contain a to distributed
Matrix okay because the expectation is
small and then the probability of
containing at least one is also is most
the
expectation and then the question is is
this also true for so this is going to
be the analog of what we did for uh for
graphs right like suppose now that the
expected number of tows is large the to
distributed Matrix the code is large
does this mean that c
almost surely contains a copy of to and
the answer is going to be just as in the
case of graphs not
necessarily okay so what do we need in
the case of graphs we also needed to
consider the expected number of
subgraphs of H okay so this if to is
analogous to some H and want comput when
ask what's the probability that H
appears in the graph then what about
subgraphs of H how do we take them into
account what's going to be
the analog the correct analog of of the
subgraph of taking the sub s s of H and
also considering its expected number of
appearances in
code so here's what it
is okay so suppose that your
code contains this to distributed Matrix
a then because of
linearity it also contains every
combination every linear combination of
The Columns of a right if I contain all
the column of a I also contain all the
linear combinations them so if I take a
and multiply it by such by a matrix to
the right say that you know B is less
than l+ one okay then I get a new Matrix
with B
columns
and containing this AB is a necessary
condition for containing
a so these sort of matrices a for you
know given matrices B these are going to
be the analogs of taking
subgraphs and the thing is that if I
know B and I know to then I also know
what's the probab the probability of
this
Matrix right because how does a random
row of this m what does a random row of
this Matrix look like a random row here
is obtained by taking a random row of a
a uniform random row of a and
multiplying it by
B so if I know that
a is distributed
to then AB is distributed Like You Know
sample something from to say some Vector
Z from to and multiply it on the right
by B so this is a new distribution that
we didn't we call this to
B so what we know now is that a
necessary condition for the code to
contain a to distributed Matrix is to
also contain a to B distributed Matrix
for every Matrix B and these are the
subgraphs okay so in order to contain a
distributed Matrix a linear code must
contain contain a to B distributed
Matrix and now we have this is the
threshold theorem for random linear
codes um so this says
that if we want to know whether a random
linear code is likely to contain a to
distributed Matrix then we need to look
at all we call them implied
distributions okay all the distributions
of the form to
B and once the rate is large enough so
that all of these go to
Infinity
then uh uh the code is likely to contain
a to distributed Matrix and until then
it's not so this is exactly and it's
really the proof is really an analog to
the to the to the proof of the theorem
about uh about random graphs it's also
obtained using uh second quick question
so it also says that when this doesn't
happen it not contain yeah so so the Upp
direction is easy right yeah so so so
the yeah it's an if and only if uh One
Direction is is easy if uh I didn't say
it explicitly right but if the expected
number of to B distributed matrices is
small then the probability of containing
a to B distributed Matrix is small but
containing a to B distributed Matrix is
necessary for containing a to
distributed Matrix so that's probability
is also so small so that's uh just by a
first moment method this is uh immediate
the other direction that if all the to
bees have large expectation than you're
likely to contain to that's not obvious
it requires this uh theorem which again
is not very hard to prove what once you
know what you what you what you're
trying to
prove one other question is
probably follow in my really um are
taking
this to see that this set of vectors
contained only you basically looking at
the dimension of this set you have this
power minus n * the dimension
of um so if
it if the sub the space t by those
Vector is
contained wouldn't all of this
uh this B how do you get this B it's
basically multiplying that set
by B is usually a you should think of b
as being a a matrix of like if your yeah
B is dimension L plus1 * B you think of
this little b as being less than L plus
one okay so you project to a smaller
Subspace yeah yeah to make for this to
make sense you like this is me this
doesn't give you anything if say B a
regular Matrix you need to to project
into a smaller uh Subspace and then okay
just like just like with the subgraphs
you also in a sense projected into right
like a part of the original graph so
it's it's the same
that's okay and this allows us to say
something about like I'm reminding you
that the original motivation for
studying all of this was during uh
research that was intended to you know
to to explore list decodability of
random linear codes I was concerned that
maybe uh Computing the expectations of
the tows is not enough and then we have
the scar lary that tells us what is
enough okay so how do we what can we do
to show that a Cod that the code the
random ler code is list decodable with
some parameters we need to show that for
every distribution to every bad
distribution every witness distribution
I you know the expected number of to
distributed matrices in C it go to zero
but that's
not the only thing we can do we're also
allowed to take some B and show that the
expected number of
t's in the random linear code goes to
zero and what we proven is is that this
is a complete method okay this method is
complete in the sense that if I want to
if I restrict myself to for every tow
finding such a b then I'm not losing
anything anything that can be proven
about random linear codes can be proven
this way okay this is the this is the
cor um and this cor also gives us again
this call it like again it's a threshold
thing right
because uh it means that for a given
towel for any towel there is some B
which is the bottleneck just one second
I'll uh uh there is some B which gives
us the bottleneck that that is like the
um this is like the the B for which like
to B requires R to be the largest in
order for the expectation to go to
infinity and then uh you start
containing a tow once you reach R
reaches the Bel neck and then it falls
very quickly the probability of being
list decodable okay the probability of
containing tow goes from very quickly
from zero to one and the probability of
being least the codable goes very
quickly from one to zero because now
you're going to it
yes you WR the statement just for f does
all of this also happen yeah all of this
holds for
fq with with some reservations I'll so
so these reservations are going to be a
key part of the next talks maybe I'll
say maybe I'll okay you asked I'll say
right now something about this for Q
constant any constant Q this holds just
the same the problem starts when for
example you want to talk about the
regime of say read Solon codes where Q
is like
n uh and one of the places where this
Falls uh fails for for large Q um is
that now you have many Okay so
that the number of uh bad
distributions uh was uh two or sorry was
like
n n to the two to the
L now in general it's going to be n to
the Q to the L and now uh you know if Q
Q is two when you're here you're good
it's constant if Q is three you're still
good if Q is n as it is in reads codes
then this is n to the N to the L and
this is not so funny anymore uh you now
you can't do a union bound over uh all
the bad distributions so you need to be
much more careful and how you approach
that so so so that's why uh for
Q being you know less
than I guess anything that's like poly
mic any you need to be less than poly
logarithmic in n and then you're still
okay beyond
that exactly
okay but yeah I mean
okay okay so okay so so just like what
okay so we proved this threshold theorem
and and what's what are the takeaways so
far so that is the codability for random
linear code can be explained by by
expectations okay this expectation
method that we've shown when when we
allow ourselves to also uh you know
multiply not just consider the bad
distributions to themselves but also
these to BS then this is a complete
method okay so anything about list
decodability friend codes can be
explained if I just like you know
anything everything if I just tell you
these expectations of the TOA and all
the to BS just like you just need to
know these terms
basically um but this holds for more
just list decodability right because
what did we really need from this like
we didn't note that in doing any of this
we didn't really delve into the
semantics of listic codability the only
we
needed two things from list codability
one is that there are short Witnesses
right if I want to show you that the
code is not list decodable I just need
to show you a small number of code words
that uh um that Witnesses this fact that
certifies this fact and the second thing
is this
symmetry
to uh Ro permutations of the of these
weakness okay so basically a property
that doesn't care about the names of the
coordinates uh uh in the code okay and
any such property the same sort of uh
the same sort of method would work you
can take this property and uh consider
your uh your Witnesses now have uh like
your Witnesses are now characterized by
your distribution so you have a set of
witnesses distributions and then you can
do the same sort of thing we did here
just for a different set of witness
distributions uh so for example this
recoverability can also be characterized
this way and for this we really need the
version of the fesal theorem that works
not for two but for larger Q okay but
again this only takes us up to any
constant Q not
for not for not
for but for any constant Q uh this still
works so we can EX for example
characterize the list recoverability
properties of random linear codes this
way and in general any property that's
uh monotone in the sense that as you
increase the code the property can only
like if if you add more code words you
can only hurt yourself right that's
monotonicity that's increasing
monotonicity of property locality you
have short Witnesses and the S to so any
property that has uh any code property
that has that uh
this okay that's
nice um but
that's somehow not interest I think I
mean I like it very much I think this is
very interesting but somehow I feel that
this is not interesting enough for me to
be talking to you about this here so
what else did we
gain so okay we again we know that
reasoning about this decodability of ROM
codes via expectations is is a complete
method but what is this good for well in
fact as a way of reasoning about random
linear codes it's not good for that much
and this is first because it doesn't
actually tell us how to prove that I
mean it it tells us that a certain
method that we already have for proving
list codability ofar codes is in fact
complete but it doesn't actually we
already had the method we just didn't
know that it's complete now we know we
we sure that's good but also there's a
very long line of works that already
showed us uh that that random linear
codes achieve the list decoding GV bound
so so this is actually a pretty known
fact by now again up to some objections
by Omar but almost uh uh but this is
almost a completely known fact for any
set of parameters so okay so it tell so
I actually showed you that a certain
method for proving something that's
already known to be true by other
methods is complete
okay but now here's the thing
we
have surpris we're going to finish even
in a good place to finish
and okay
um so yeah so now all of these results
that already exist which were proven by
many people some of them are in this
room about list decodability
of uh uh random linear codes in fact
tell us something about expectations
right uh because if I know for some
other contrived reasons that random
linear code achieves the G down and G
and that means that for every witness
distribution there
exists some Matrix B such that the
expected number of to BS in the random
linear code is small and this is
something I learned now for the fresh
for the fresh fear I didn't know that
just from these proofs because these
proofs worked in completely different
ways but they all tell me this fact
about uh uh about these matrices uh
about these uh expectations of the tow
bees
okay so how do I use this fact I can now
use this to talk about other random
ensembles of codes and I'm going to I'm
actually going to show that many other
codes also achieve the same list
decoding cap also achieve the same list
decoding properties of random linear
codes so for this I need the definition
I'm going to Define uh uh when a random
code a random code symble just think of
a think of a random code okay like if a
random code
that's if some distributed somehow okay
taken from some other distribution not
random linear code but some other
distribution of codes so we say that
this random code is similar locally
similar to random linear code if you
remember the only thing you need to know
about random linear
codes if this other code
C approximately satisfies this same
thing okay that the probability of
containing a small set is roughly the
same as in a random linear code any code
that does that we say that it is locally
similar to a random linear
code and what we can now prove is that
every and there are there do exist
locally similar uh like there do exist
codes that satisfy this definition we're
going to talk about later uh but right
now I can tell you that every code
satisfying this definition every code
that's locally similar to random linear
code um also takes the same ltic
codability
properties that were uh that were gained
with high work with a lot of work about
random linear
codes so let's this is the only like
slide where I actually like show a proof
uh because it's important um I'm going
to go over quick quickly but it it is
going to be written for you so yeah so
the FM is that if a code C is locally
similar to random linear code then for
example it achieves the list decoding GV
bound with high
probability okay how do we prove this so
let D be a random linear code and we
know from previous works that D achieves
with high probability achieves the
listic um okay so take some row and L
and and we want to show that every Row
in L for which D is list decodable our
code C the locally similar code is also
going to be list decodable with these
parameters okay so let to be some
witness distribution okay so T is going
to be a row cluster
distribution so we know that D the
random linear code is is is is less
decod probably decodable so it's
unlikely to contain
to by the threshold
theorem if how can it be unlikely to
contain to there must be some such that
the the expected number of to
distributed matrices goes to
zero but because of local similarity
what's the expected number of of t b
distributed matrices in
C
it's the number of to B distributed
matrices times the probability for each
Matrix that it's contained in C but this
is the same as the probability that this
Matrix is contained in D because these
are small sets of vectors and local
similarity tells us that this is going
to be the same uh term here but so this
is exactly also the expected number of
to B distributed matrices in D it's the
same thing okay so local similarity of C
random codes mean means that the
expected number of matrices with some
given distribution is going to be the
same so this distribution goes to zero
and then that means that this
distribution also goes to
zero but if the expected number of to B
distributed matrices in C goes to zero
then C does not contain is unlikely to
contain a to B distributed Matrix
because the expectation the expected
number of such matrices go to zero but
then it's also unlikely to contain to
because containing to B is necessary for
continuing
to
um okay so this is like a generic
reduction now in order to show that a
code is as list
decodable as a random linear code I just
need to show local
similarity yes SC right no C is a Rand
no C is a random code a random code but
by some other code distribution in a
second we're actually going to be
talking about two certain distributions
for which this
holds um and okay and this again is
going to work also for example for list
recovery so if we have a cool result
about list recoverability of random
linear codes when it immediately
transfers to C to this Rand to this
other random code as well and even if
you know even if in the future we
discover some new better results about
list cability of friend leader because
we're also going to transfer to C
immediately like you also it's this
uh fed in which is cool so one question
so this approximately equal probability
you allow some Epsilon in the exponent
that's yeah it's
uh this like minus one minus r plus
yes
okay so here's a technique uh using
Mary's
Hammer um how do I show that a code
achieves the list the coding GV
bound so I start from a random code
emble of my choice I show that that it
is locally similar to random linear code
and then I use the f I just showed to
conclude that it achieves the the list
Cod course the tough part is how do I
show a certain code locally similar to a
random linear
code so this was actually done
successfully for two code
ensembles uh one is the ensemble
of uh random ldpc codes and known as
gager emble so these are uh codes where
the parity check Matrix is essentially
the parity check Matrix is a random
sparse
Matrix and the first work this is the
first work uh that the fresh are
Computing with n no sh and Mary uh uh
and there with use these terms exactly
but essentially we show that
um random Spar like these random sparse
matrices uh uh our parity check matrices
for codes which are locally similar to
random linear codes and then conclude
cility and again also that for example
Vera's list covered as random
code and later this was also done for a
set of ensembles uh randomly punctured
low bias codes Okay so you start from a
code of low bias a code of low bias is
so in the binary case just think of a
code where the uh weights okay that a
code that has good distance like the
weights are close to one half but also
from above like the weights cannot to
like we're not too small but we're also
not too large you know between like a
half minus Epsilon and half plus Epsilon
or something you take such a code and
you apply random puncturing to it which
is something we're going to be talking
about tomorrow um and this gives you
some random code uh that's uh locally
similar to random linear code so we've
show that all every code that can be
described this way um is as list
decodable as a random ler code
soch okay uh a few words about what
we're going to do next so one thing is
we're going to explore this okay so this
result and then we're going to be
talking about the bad here and some the
bad is really that okay we want to
eventually be talking about listic
codability of read Sol codes and the
problem again is that the method I
showed you right now is not enough to do
that uh because it doesn't work when Q
is large so we'll be exploring why it
doesn't work like trying to fine tune
more precisely what's the problem uh
from large Q
case and then we'll see ways to overcome
that okay uh I think that's it for now
thank
you excellent talk and leaving us
suspense tomorrow any questions can
quickly comment on how you apply the
thres serum for just random linear codes
how you you want to show for every C
there's some like how do you make that
happen um are you talking about how do
you actually use that to okay so so so
the idea in theory would be the
following right so for example consider
um consider the uh that you're really
trying to show that a um that random
linear code is list
decodable so you need to think about all
the possible tows now one to that's easy
to that's like the obvious one and it's
easy to to show that the that there you
get like very the expectation goes to
zero is just think about uh l+ one
vectors with no linear dependenc between
them that Som all fall into the same
bolt and this is really easy to to
compute now the problems start when you
need to also consider uh when you do
have linear dependencies so for example
The Other Extreme case is think about uh
you have l+ one vectors but the
dimension is just log of L plus one okay
so it's like we have like you have a
small hadamar code or right like all the
something like that and then uh um and
then you somehow need to to to to go
over all the possible like you you need
to to see which distributions with these
uh um uh um which distributions of rows
that have these linear dependencies
between them uh give you uh like all
fall into the same into a row shaped
ball and you need into a radius row ball
and you need to somehow pick like the
worst case one would be the one that has
the largest entropy of all of these
distributions right so it's an you go
into entropy maximization problems of
course it's also possible that uh um
someone that's there is an distribution
with smaller
entropy uh that like the distribution of
the largest entropy versus some B that
reduces it to much smaller entropy but
vers so so so it's not clear that you
always that that the adversary you would
always want the largest entropy one
because because if there's also these
bees involved uh um I think that maybe
gives you uh a feeling about why this is
still a tough problem even uh even when
you have this fear and like even this me
like I mean eventually the ways in which
uh uh the ways for which uh uh these
results for random linear codes were
were eventually obtained was not through
this method and I think there's a reason
for that like using this method is using
this meod to actually argue about random
inar codes is
hard one more question there and then
maybe out for lunch you have
question no
okay Qui question right okay can may
give a quick comment actually just to
follow up on what Jonathan was saying I
think um you know I've worked a bit
about actually using this
characterization to compute the
threshold rate and I think I for like
binary codes we can do it for like like
list of three decoding and list four
decoding I still already too hard to
solve just because already there you
have to like look at you know sets of
size five and like all the different
ways you can project them down and that
just becomes too many combinatorial
things to keep track of at least for me
so that's already kind of where we're
stuck maybe I'll say one more thing
about this is that actually when you let
Q be large then okay this this method
specifically doesn't work for this for
but actually when you
allow Q to be large and take like the
analog of this method that we're going
to talk about tomorrow that does work
then it's actually
easier uh because for large Q uh no
entrop because entropy is much easier to
to work with the the the Q entropy uh
function is just linear so it's that
makes the the things
easier so I GA that you don't get a
completely new proof and you can Trash
the old results but you
have like you need it's the opposite you
need the old results and then this proof
G gives you the the possibility to
reduce them to like to reduce from other
Cod to
random maybe I'll ask a question based
on Nick's comment is there a proof using
this method only that shows random
you're do it or is it um explode so so
so so there is one for very like for
large Q it's uh also it's like it's not
on the archive yet it will be on AR so
there is one for large that possible to
ad like the ghk argument didn't wein
yeah I think one of yeah I think the the
guruswami HED karti proof is entially
can essentially be seen as as as using
this method well yeah you just use their
ideas Al the old pin zbl of argument is
also like can also be seen as using this
method but in a very you know in a very
crude way there also some for smallness
yeah exactly and then it's just counting
doing everything by hand yeah at least I
have no more clever ideas at this point
oh we do have something for
um
no all right so thanks again and thank
you so we meet again at 2:00 for uh back
to back